اكيد الاكل في الفضاء كما في افلام الخيال
العلمي وفي ارض الواقع حلول مبتكره لايجاد
ايجاد وصنع هذا الطعام خارج الارض هذا
الابتكار تقدمه ناسا بالفعل شركه في
بروكلين ابتكرت طريقه لاعاده تدوير ثاني
اكسيد الكربون الذي يخرجه رواد الفضاء
اثناء الطيران لصنع مواد غذائيه مبنيه على
الخميره لا خلاص كلنا ننتقل للعيش في
الفضاء في اكل فمن هذه الخميره يمكن تكوين
مشروب من البروتين يهدف الى تغذيه رواد
الفضاء الذين يقومون بمهمات طويله الامد
في الفضاء العميق كما يمكن استخدام نفس
العمليه لانتاج بدائل اخرى مليئه
بالكاربوهيدرات لاعداد خبز ومكرونه وخبز
التورتيلا
طبعا شجع تحدي الغذاء في الفضاء العميق
الذي تراه ناسه لانتاج البروتينات
والكربوهيدرات والدهون الصالحه للاكل من
نفس النظام اذا ستطلبين ستطلبين اثنين
اثنين ثاني اكسيد الكربون وكثر طحينه
عليها
كبسه مثلا
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات